Wendy Williams tears up after a
three-month hiatus from her talk show
[Applause]
I'm doing better now let's get started
it's nice to hear wendy is doing well
the 54 year old TV personality made her
long-awaited return and address some hot
topics including her health and rumors
about her marriage being on the rocks
I want a shout out to my husband I'm
still wearing my ring he's my best
friend he's my lover he's all this and
he's all back I know what you've been
seeing and I knew what the streets have
been talking about Wendy set the record
straight on reports that her husband
Kevin hunter allegedly had a years-long
affair with a massage therapist I'm
still very much in love with my husband
and anybody who's been married for five
minutes or five hundred years you know
marriages have abs and flows marriages
are not easy and don't ask me about mine
until you see this Vaughn ace or self et
that Wendy's husband Kevin was backstage
at the show Monday for her return to the
small stream our source adds it's not
unusual for him to be at the studio with
her it's not a deal it's not a big thing
for you know Kevin and Kevin to come
with me to doctor's appointments
Kevin was also on hand as Wendy went to
the doctor to manage complications from
her Grey's disease and a shoulder
fracture Wendy gave an update on her
help since taking the extended break we
were supposed to only be off for two
weeks for Christmas vacation and towards
the end of the two weeks I started to
feel thyroid ish well they're still
adjusting my meds and if you don't know
about thyroid disease it's it's if it's
a lifetime thing and they're always
adjusting and always doing stuff and it
can really screw you over and so they're
adjusting my thyroid meds and then
eyeballs attached to the thyroid which
is mygrades disease and then you know I
always have the equilibrium thing with
my vertigo and a million other things
and I'm the kind of patient if I call
I'm thinking I'm dying I know I've
gotten to that point and I'm happy to
tell you that I am doing swell Wendy
says she doesn't plan on leaving her
iconic purple chair again because she
has changed her overall lifestyle I'm
going to the gym seven days a week for
two hours a day I don't know how this
outfit is reading on TV but mother has
not gained a pound in her absence the
show had guest hosts taking over the
show including Jerry O'Connell Sherri
Shepherd you guys we are praying and we
are loving on Wendy can you tell when do
we love you when and Nick Cannon we
jumped on the phone at first did you say
Nick Cannon how you doing when I spoke
to her she just said she feels y'all
love last month the Wendy Williams Show
praised all the fill-in sharing in a
statement quote we so appreciate all of
the guest hosts and panelists who filled
in for Wendy during this time these
people are and always will be true
family to the show
[Music]
[Applause]